first of all actually I want to sort of
get to a little breaking news that just
happened right before we came online and
there's not that here on at the Disney
Interactive blog from a 1 John black
born who is the senior vice president
and GM of Disney infinity to quote him
he says by now you may have already
heard the news that we have made the
difficult decision to discontinue
production of Disney infinity from the
beginning Disney infinity was built for
you our fans and wanted to take a moment
to thank you not just for your support
over ears but forgetting community that
made Disney infinity more than just a
game our goal for disney infinity was to
bring the best of this in storytelling
to life in homes around the world with
your support we accomplished that we
hope and that you have as much playing
at the game as we had making it so
what's next for disney infinity we have
two final retail releases coming
including three new characters from
Allah street looking glass later this
month and from finding Dory the place
that does the new movie pics are
releasing in a couple of weeks and place
s launching in June and as we turn to
the next chapter in the story I want to
thank everyone who helped bring Disney
infinity to life particularly disney's
glendale based production and publishing
teams are external development partners
and of course the incredible avalanche
team for the tireless dedication to this
project but most of all i want to thank
you again for making disney infinity a
part of our lives and for making for
adding to the disney legacy by being
part of this community I'm a little
shocked I thought these games were
selling well oh yeah they bought Star
Wars and we're going to milk it in every
possible way right I mean I played three
point oh I haven't played any of the
other ones and I played three point oh
and I actually really enjoyed it for
water was you you're a father of
children around you tell me because for
me I was like I was almost taken aback
by how playable I mean it wasn't like
the most magnificent 3d platformer may
but it was kind of enough substance
there to make it an enjoyable play but I
kind of didn't really figure I'd I
couldn't figure out what age group it
was for yeah I definitely like I
experiment with games with my kids and
like they like sitting in my lap and
watch me play destiny for some reason
and I heard his neat i through disney
infinity at them one of the more recent
Star Wars updates and I got to see like
for at least 25 year olds it was still a
little bit too complicated right I'm
like the Ewok village
some really complex puzzle platforming
and the combat was actually pretty
robust with like combo attacks and
things like that so it depends like I
think maybe a seven year old could
really related to disney infinity for
kids younger than that it was still a
little bit too challenging although I
will say they did enjoy ripping the arms
off of like the ahsoka tano statue that
I had I mean that's the other part of it
as well as that this whole toys to life
thing we very much gotten the impression
i think is consumers that it must be
doing really well i mean amiibos ER
we've got a couple of amoeba Latics here
in the office and then the same with
Skylanders as well like they seem to be
like whenever I go to a friend's house
and got kids and they got a game console
they tend to either have some infinity
or Skylanders stuff apparently that
wasn't enough for them either I mean
ultimately the business model for any
toy seller is to get it the parents
wallets through their kid you got to get
the kid to ask the parent for the toy
and that's when the parents usually say
yes right because parents aren't gonna
for the most part go buy this stuff on
their own so to me that says that they
didn't connect with the kids right now
cuz they're they're the target market
like I guess when you think about what
are the big disney games that have come
out in the past couple years I'd like I
don't know if there was a frozen
playlist or place out on this maybe
there was me but it wasn't I mean you're
talking about monsters inc and
Incredibles and stuff like that which
are kind of a couple years old now and a
couple of years in child's toys is like
a lifetime right yeah and so maybe the
Star Wars I don't know it just seems
crazy that they're literally tanking
this entire project yeah based off of
what apparently is low sailor like I
don't know the thought Disney were flush
at the moment yeah as a few years ago
right before disney infinity came out
when i was i sat down to play at GDC and
i remember thinking and this was before
they even had like Star Wars so I was
thinking okay Disney plus like toys like
Skylanders by this point proven to be
really lucrative and they were only
unlike their second game I mean yeah
that was originally a Spyro spinoff so
it was essentially that was a pitch take
Skylanders edit to Disney and then you
can sell the models which like even from
a collector's standpoint that seems like
it'd be lucrative but also like either
well made toys I've bought like five or
six of those model sets in the bone to
my shame yeah and they're sitting like
only because I'm like I'm a
fine of up and I'm a fan of like inside
out so I like I have and they're like
they were relatively inexpensive
actually as why was the other thing in
the sets so but yes still like you think
Disney fans would buy anything that
seems like the perfect storm of
everything a kid or like a lot of adults
would like that especially the
collectors mindset the fact that if
you're in a games you can like them and
then if it coalesce is with your
interest in toys that's just a perfect
combination that I'm very surprised as
well that that's it wasn't going as well
as I thought I will say that my kids
have surprised me um some of this might
and is just my speculation but some of
this might be because a lot of kids
these days we'll watch other kids play
with toys on YouTube right rather than
play with toys themselves much in the
same way how like our generations
baffled when people watch gamers play
games on YouTube rather than just you
know back in my day we played the games
ourselves yes you know I had a friend of
our family sorry friend and families
sons stay over an hour place over the
weekend and for his like 14th birthday
and I was out like he I gave him like
five four to play some fallout 4 any
played it for about 30 minutes and then
actually this is more fun to watch yeah
so yeah it's too complicated from
there's a weird trend these days we're
like kids and even young adults get on
YouTube and they just sort of cathartic
Lee watch other people do it rather than
do it themselves yeah I wonder if the
toy market it's like adelson porn yeah
disney infinity has Marvel to I can't
believe that right like I keep
forgetting how many like how much they
have unlike in their court for that I
now I want to know how Skylanders are
doing yeah I Gannon I mean I know that
was the precursor to that whole like
genre but i can't imagine they're doing
really well if Marvel and Disney and
Pixar are not selling these toys in
these games weird very strange I guess
you know all we can say is sort of our
thoughts glad to everyone who worked on
production for a Disney infinity and I
hope you guys land on your feet and yeah
I made a really great game regardless of
what happened to it and best of luck and
yeah hopefully with your more about this
over the next days and weeks as people
start to sort of comment flesh out the
story agency no that's just breaking it
just as real
you